[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
um you know something was really sweet
uh i got a
a message from nico who is a um
he's a listener he's a patron and um
you can join patreon patreon.com inside
of you and uh
amazing kids family zach love that kid
but he said he was watching america's
got talent
and uh so i checked this clip out and of
course
you know simon callow got emotional i i
got a little emotional watching it
but this girl who you know faced a lot
of adversity she sang the song and it
was beautiful
but more importantly she said something
after the song
she said something that was so profound
and beyond her years
that i had to rewind it and i had to
write it down i had to write this [ __ ]
down
and it was this she said you can't wait
until life isn't hard anymore
before you decide to be happy
you can't wait until life isn't hard
anymore before you decide to be happy
that struck a chord man
and i just thought isn't that what we're
always waiting for we're waiting for
well once things get a little easier
once life isn't hard
then i'll be able to be happy i'll be
able to get my [ __ ] together
get your it's it's time now
to be happy even while things are hard
even while things are
so i you know goes back to you me who
goes back to everybody listening i just
[ __ ] man talk about a mental health
moment that was a i i
teared up i i had a little cry there
what was her talent she was a singer but
i just thought about that i was like you
know i gotta wait till my anxiety is
is on track i gotta wait till everything
is right before you know then i
then i'll feel happy um and it's kind of
[ __ ] it's like
finding ways to be happy now through it
all it just hit me i don't know does it
not hit you
no of course it does yeah yeah it's not
that your issues my issues aren't
important and whatever but
in the scheme of things i guess in life
it's just you know
you know i won't dwell on it too much
but you can't wait until life isn't hard
anymore before you decide to be happy
and i thought that was really neat so
anyway welcome to the show i hope you're
having a great
week um great guest this week before
i get into the guest the lovely keegan
allen
um if you're here for keegan if you're
here for uh just enjoyment uh
a good interview please subscribe ryan
tell them where they could subscribe and
keep supporting the podcast oh you could
subscribe the podcast is everywhere you
can find the podcast apple podcast
stitcher
uh spotify and you can find us on
youtube
you can watch it uh youtube.com inside
of you with michael rosenbaum
yes and what are the candidates for
inside of you follow us you can follow
at insideviewpot on twitter and
insidetobepodcast on instagram and
facebook that's right
that's very easy and we really love that
if you write a review we love you even
more
um i have to say if you go to uh hello
at inside of you podcast and leave
messages
it's very hard because they get really
stacked up with messages and it takes me
a couple of months to go through them
and sort through them and
i respond sometimes the the big
long-winded emails i kind of absorb and
i don't really respond to because it's
sometimes too hard but like short one
line two lines those are easy to respond
to
and uh but some people feel like they
need to tell me a story and so be it but
i
it's it's sometimes i it's hard for me
to get to it
and you know just don't expect me to get
to it or
however not don't expect me to have a
response to it
always um the inside of you store we got
some new stuff we got these awesome
uh journals i thought that was very
appropriate for the podcast that you
know it's a journal to write your life
in
all your [ __ ] that's going on in your
life and uh you know journal i journal
every day
and so the little leather journal books
uh you can get them autographed or you
can get them non-autographed there's
also um masks new inside masks and those
are going pretty fast so are the
journals
so go to the inside of you online store
and uh in fact
use this code summer rosie 10
for 10 off at the store summer rosy 10
and in fact you know
if you want sun spin stuff from the band
um we've got tons of sunshine stuff go
to sunspin.com
um and you can use the code
sun spin summer 10. and that's going to
be uh 10
off everything in the sunspin store uh
the inside of you store has a bunch of
other stuff too
uh lex funko pops and smallville lunch
boxes and all that [ __ ]
i'm going to read a letter at the end
from a fan i thought it was kind of
touching it was one of those letters
that i actually read and printed out but
uh
and uh don't forget to join patreon uh
i'm on it
if you love the podcast if you're
enjoying it you want to get back to the
podcast a little more or something
you can do that by going to patreon.com
inside of you
i've got a lot of patrons and there's
tears for uh you
you know i send merch to certain um
tiers
with little notes every couple months
and um
you get to ask guest questions and you
get to do a q a with me so it's you get
to ask me questions on my q a segment
which ryan was a part of
last month do you remember that i do
remember that yeah i liked that that was
easy you just asked me questions
interested you were great at it i can
read you can read and if anyone had any
doubts
join patreon and go watch that video
today's guest
interesting guy um we talk about pretty
little liars we talked about
art painting photography photography
this guy's world-class just a a great
guy he's on the show walker he's been in
tons of stuff
and uh we had a great conversation i
really think you're gonna enjoy it so
why don't we just get right into keegan
allen
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
oh god how are you doing man i'm good
man you know look it's
jared paddle lucky your buddy on walker
he was like you got to get keegan on the
show that's one of the first things he
said
he must like you because i don't think
he'd say that you guys get along pretty
well huh
i i adore him i think he's i think he's
really a special
guy for sure and uh and it's also also
really cool too because i
i i've i've uh i watched smallville when
i was when i was younger and i really
think honestly you're the best uh
lex luthor come on oh dude you you
actually brought grounded reality to
that character
i feel like every other actor that
played lex luthor was who okay so let's
go through who played listen oh god you
put me on the spot
right yeah gene but he you know he
played it like in a crazy fun way he's
always my favorite but yeah
i know what you're saying okay gene
hatman so here's the thing i you leaned
into a grounded
reality gene hackman played it up it was
campy
he did it it was interesting but you
were grounded you
you felt i felt for your character i
remember being a child and watching that
show
and being like oh wow lex luthor man
well you know right there thank you but
i have to give
i was gonna say i give props to i mean
the whole production i've talked about
it but like
you know from the writing to the
director photography to the
special effects to everything that it
just it just turned into a really great
show but um
thank you i mean uh you know you always
do your best you never know how fans are
going to react and i wasn't a big
superman fan growing up so
but hearing that from someone who
watched the show and like
you know i just i just really appreciate
that that's nice well you you rose above
all of the other
actors that tried that attempted to i
mean obviously
outside of the animated versions of this
character
i mean you brought you brought a real
humanity to the character i felt like
you know kevin spacey was a little nuts
uh jesse eisenberg's like you know he's
fine but
you i every time i think lex luthor i
think of you
i think of you pushing your father off
the bat of the building
it's good man uh we had some fun john
glover and i terrific actor
well look you know the great thing
there's there's a the great thing is
hearing you say this
it's very kind of you but it's also it
sucks because i can't respond
and like i can't tell you what i think
of other because then i sound like a
dick
but like i don't but but no well i'm not
in terms of like you know
other actors i i respect all the actors
that have played it but you know
i think it comes down to you know
preference i mean
personal choice but also like uh
i don't know it's that's everything's
subjective i just wanted to say i
i have a reverence for for your work in
that and also
i've been you know enjoying your talks
uh you know
throughout the last however many years
that you've been doing the podcast
circuit
i loved you on theovan i thought it was
very uh fun and controversial
very interesting dude theo vaughn let me
tell you about something
i went on theo vaughn's show i walk in
there it's almost like he
i love theo and this isn't knocking him
but it almost was like you know
i don't know if he was like you know
being david letterman
or what he was doing but i walk in and
he's just got a pen
and he's writing and he's he's not
really paying any attention to me when i
walk in at all which
as an actor like what the [ __ ] man give
me some love here he's like
hey man and he's just kind of doing his
thing like he's like this really
intense interview and i'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah
deal's going uh method for this uh
you know for this interview and then of
course he's like so tell me about
allison mack you know and starts getting
into that right away and
you know i gave him yeah and i gave him
[ __ ] because
i'm like hey come back on my podcast man
you're hilarious and blah blah he's like
yeah i want to man i'm just real busy
you know he's a good guy but
i'm like dude you got two million hits
off that
interview with the whole thing with
allison mack in my interview
come back on my freaking show so uh but
anyway theo theo's
one of the one of the funniest people on
the planet honestly he is
he's so unique even when you ask other
comedians who are you know my friend
harlan williams you know the guy from
dumb and dumb or the guy who's like you
drinking on some of grandpa's cough
medicine there buddy
yeah yeah he goes yeah theo vaughn
is really funny man i mean that guy's a
freaking character bot
and he is he's a he's a he's a funny guy
but look back
we got to put the direction on you the
focus on you now all right let's do it
oh man this this is scary
first of all you have a great name
keegan allen is that your real name
it's my real name i know why do i get
michael rosenbaum
and you get keegan allen well look i
it was almost it was almost a totally
different very jewish name i mean
but my dad changed his uh his last name
what was his last name i actually don't
know because
uh he was very secretive about his last
name
so but i do know that he wanted to have
a flow and a last name that was very uh
easy to say and so and then my name
which i found out what it meant from
disneyland of all the places
not a very interesting but you know one
of those uh you know those like things
where you put the
quarter in and it generates uh the name
thing right when i was very young and
it's a celtic name that means little
fiery one
which was an eco booster at the age of
six
your little fiery one keegan keegan yeah
little fiery one i like that were your
parents uh pretty cool growing up i mean
you said jewish
did you were you bar mitzvahed i was not
barb mitzvahed um
i was actually well i had a choice to uh
kind of my mother's jewish and my father
is was catholic and i kind of oscillated
between religions growing up
um but i i i
you know now it's i'm a bit agnostic but
i'm more spiritual
i'm more into i'm more into spirituality
than
the idea of religion now which is which
is very comfortable
nice and your parents so they didn't
really stick religion on you at all
they'll kind of let you go your own way
no my parents were extraordinary in that
they were both artists
so they cared so much about not caring
but in a in a really logical way in a
way that let me
be free and they supported my art they
supported
when i was down when i was sad uh
they let me be the person that i wanted
to be
and it was an interesting
you know experience growing up where i
saw all my friends
being controlled very controlled and
like
held down by their parents constructs of
who they
the parents wanted them to be and my
parents were like look go do whatever
you want to do if
you [ __ ] up it's on you and where was
this where where did you grow up
i grew up in in hollywood you grew up in
hollywood
yeah that's right you wrote a book about
it
yeah i have a photography book called
hollywood and stories and voices from
foreverland
that is a love letter to growing up in
in hollywood okay i i saw that book i
know i know what you're talking about
now but it was like it was
pictures so when i heard book i thought
i was thinking something else but like i
saw
some of the pictures and everything i
was like holy crap this guy does
photography and he he he sings he's got
a song
i mean and the song's beautiful that
song had to be it's called million miles
away right
yeah yeah that a million miles away and
it had to be put in a tv show you had to
get that placed
i i mean i here's the thing about all my
music
i i am so i'm a hopeless romantic
i love i love the idea of being in love
and i've always felt that way and i
learned to feel from the movies i
learned to feel from
good books and literature growing up and
poems
and shakespeare and there was something
really like
haunting and romantic about writing love
songs
and uh so a lot of any kind of
music that has been you know aggregated
into my life
from the outside world it comes through
me in like a really
like very syrupy it's like spoon feeding
ice cream too much like i love
music but i feel like i've with i've
like held back a lot of music from
releasing it because i feel like
sometimes it's a bit too much like it's
a bit like
lame but well you say lame but like if
it's coming from the heart they always
say whatever you're doing
if you have feeling and you mean it
that's when it's the best right whether
it's
acting or whether it's music so if it's
coming out in your music
maybe you shouldn't hold back and you
should just let it go and go this is
what i'm feeling this is what i'm
writing and
people either gravitate towards it or
they won't so yeah yeah
yeah i mean and growing up i had like
interesting i had an
interesting relationship with music my
parents you know they
they introduced me to you know music
like
bob dylan and the grateful dead and van
morrison
and the doors very very controversial
music for a very young person especially
bob dylan which i took to and i just was
obsessed with bob dylan
growing i was very young i'm still
obsessed with him to this day but
um his music was so interesting to me
because i mean he
absolutely jump-started this the era of
folk um you know protester
music and at a time when
people's voices needed to be heard he he
was creating these
beautiful lyrical structure almost like
a rap
now would be a rap battle he was doing
that and it to me it was just
it was unlike anything i'd ever heard
and anything i've ever heard up until
now
he was you know putting his heart on his
sleeve and
you know millions of other people's
hearts on there honestly what are you
saying so
that elliot smith yeah i really
experienced him growing up tragic
tragic ending magic tragic but just made
the music
just so much deeper and oh man even now
you want to have a sunny day and ruin it
elliott smith elliott smith uh
nick drake does that to me as well but
he's kind of soothing
dude you know nick drake is another
horrifically
just that when you listen to his music
and you hear that stroke i mean there's
no other
musician like nick drake no yeah i mean
you put on any of his albums
there's a pink pink moon pink moon yeah
you put on pink moon
and it transports you to another like a
it's so
cerebral yeah and it's almost timeless
it feels like it's
you know you could be listening to
something in the 70s but you could be
listening to something in the 90s or
now it's just it just it does but it
transports you into something just
soothing and uh yeah it's it's good
music
uh but i think that you shouldn't be
afraid
to do that i just came out with an album
and you know i'm 48 years old i'm not
gonna be a freaking rock star but i love
music and i love and i try not to think
of lyrics so much as like i have to be
so
brilliant in these lines and i want
people to be
you know i want to evoke all these and
you just kind of
write music and you play it and you sing
it and you say what you feel and you
you know and i just think that when i
listened to that song i just felt like
yeah i could tell what you're saying
it's just very
it's it's it's how you're feeling it's
just a very
i think that's important though i think
you should continue doing that how many
how many
i mean i will i will it's there's you
know i i've have had this
you walk the line you know with with
something i mean i like to dip my toe
into every
thing creatively like right now i'm
painting i'm taking a painting class
with one of my favorite
plein air painters that he's i reached
reached out to him and i was like hey
you know he's amazing his name is jesse
powell
amazing like oh like it'll blow your
mind he's so
talented and with plein air what's nuts
is
i mean as an actor you can you can you
can understand the objective of a scene
you read a script
you go okay who am i what am i trying to
say
what is the writer trying to say how do
i marry that
what does the scene warrant what are the
notes like all of that
is is all it's a topography of thought
but when you're painting something
compositionally you're creating
something that you see it's your
perspective same
same thing with acting but like what's
so mystifying about plein air
oil painting is you can just hodge podge
a bunch of paint
in an area and up close it it just looks
like nothing
and then you step back and it's this
perfect
composition of an exact perspective
and it transports you to that moment and
uh i've been trying to understand that
because it's all just shadows and
highlights that's
it there's no it's all your perspective
it's the perspective that's being
kind of like it's not being forced it's
like the hand of someone else just like
you're being like here
let me show you this so remarkable what
what got you into that see so for me
i was going through a tough time i had
like a lot of anxiety i was dealing with
a lot of [ __ ] and i just said i need to
check out and i went to connecticut
across the country and i checked in for
three weeks of this place and um
you know it was just i had to get my
mind straight and i started doing
art and i hate i hated sorry i hated art
because
i didn't realize it but as a kid i was
this color-blind kid who
uh i just i just never did well in art
class i was the only kid who got like
d's or
f's and art i had a short attention span
i've talked about that but all of a
sudden
i hate art and even going in high school
i'd smell the art
you know art class and i'd walk around a
different different way because i just
wanted to get as far away as i could and
was hoping i didn't have to take our
class and so they
i don't want to say forrest but they
said they really
told me that it's important to try it
just try
something uh you don't have to be great
at and for me i've always had to be
great at everything i feel like i have
to
i have to prove myself i have to show
everybody how great i am and and with
this i started art and
i started doing with my friends at the
house i'm not
good i'm not even remotely good but
there's something that takes me away
that just takes me away from the present
or makes me actually
more present and not and disconnects me
from
sort of all these other external things
of you know trying too hard and
impressing in this
and i noticed that that 30 minutes or
that hour or whatever it takes
it's just for me it's it's just being
and there's something really nice about
it now
is that why you started doing that yeah
i mean my mother is a
as a painter she does watercolor and
that's
fascinating to me because it works
backwards from oil
um you know you're working on your your
you build on watercolor whereas and you
build on oil but it's
it's reversed you know you would you
wouldn't be able to i mean you could i
mean technically
put put down a darker color and then
paint lighter
but what's what's interesting is that
growing up both my parents were painters
and they did it as like uh you know my
dad would
do these sprawling paintings with
acrylic and oil all over the place and
my mom's doing watercolor paint
my dad was an actor so he was constantly
doing very thespian things in the house
and emoting and um you know it was a
very dramatic
upbringing because they're you know
being around two artists you
you know it's it's chaos i mean it's
chaos but it's
there's something beautiful about the
chaos um
but getting into painting recently has
been therapeutic i've
i've really i've noticed that because of
all of the uh
the media and the intensity in the world
right now
um it's very easy to like um your
brain becomes a blender of other
people's
thoughts and emotions and um
you know it's very easy to slip into
this vortex of energy now
that never before has it been this easy
um i mean if you want to feel
you know complete cosmogonic chaos you
can step
into any social media realm right now
you could step into anything and find
yourself
overwhelmed you know so i've been
working on like doing meditation
uh because i was having panic attacks
over nothing i just there was nothing
happening i was having really bad
anxiety really bad panic attacks
so i've been doing lots of meditation
lots of yoga
um lots of painting playing music
listening to me taking time just to do
nothing to swim
go on walks how much does that help you
how much to honestly
because you know go back to your
childhood you said there was
it was a little chaotic it was dramatic
it was all these things
do you think did it did it was it in a
good way
or was it both in a good way in a bad
way did it create some anxiety did you
did you feel stressed were there did you
have that teenage angst
you know that man my first book was all
my teenage angst
all of it lifelong beauty was all
written
uh i was i was i was like i was teen
angst for most of my
life until i like hit i think like 25
and then i was like oh man i gotta
i gotta like figure this out um but
yeah i growing up i mean i feel i feel
like everybody has
the same story in a different way
and my angst growing up lent itself
to now finding the peace to know that it
was okay to feel
down and sad sometimes and it's okay to
feel down and sad
even now but to to not linger
to not linger too far into those
feelings and understand that they're
just thoughts and
feelings and you can be a passenger to
those moments and then
like because nothing here's the other
thing michael like nothing really
matters
everything is temporary and that's the
greatest
awakening that i had was in my like 20
in my late 20s
i was like oh wow like nothing is
forever like everything's temporary so
like to
live in the moment and be present in
yourself
it helps but you know if you're having
anxiety and you're having depression
sometimes
you have to go a little bit deeper into
why you know and what
what how did you go deeper i did i have
been i've been um
i've been really examining uh you know
i've had a this is a
a real amazing blessing to work on a
show like
walker and have just such an amazing
supportive group of people around
and a collaborative environment and um
and one where we we all feel already
like a family
so coming to work i'm i'm i'm in a very
i'm in a very happy
place a very good environment an
environment that promotes creation and
um promotes creativity in a way that
you know it allows me then to focus
on my off time on things that make me a
better
better person a better man a better
human
um because i feel like you know
especially now especially in my life now
i'm i mean
i'm in my 30s and i'm just starting to
understand when my dad would be like you
just wait till you're older and you'll
understand like i'm
just now getting
the light from that conversation in the
distance and i'm like oh
starting to get it you know
inside of you is brought to you by geico
ryan we've talked about this ad nauseam
but there's only one place you go for
bundling policies if you don't want to
waste time paying your auto policy to
this guy and your
home insurance to this guy geico is
there
geico's omnipresent aren't they they're
ubiquitous
yes they're omniscient they know
everything
geico makes it easy for us that's what
they're doing here they're just trying
to make it easy on you
with great rates and on top of it
taking care of you so you don't have to
make all these payments to different
people geico makes it easy to bundle
your homeowners or renters insurance
along with your auto policy
because we have so much to do so much
going on in our lives ryan uh that's for
sure
we we don't need to take the time to pay
millions of people we just pay one geico
just go to geico.com get a quote and see
how much you
could save it's geico easy visit
geico.com today that's
geico.com inside you is brought to you
by helix
sleep i think we all know that sleep is
the number one most important thing
in life there's nothing like having a
great sleep and there's nothing worse
than having a bad sleep i for one suffer
from
you know a lot of surgeries and pain and
things in my life and i need comfort and
that's why helix sleep is right for me
it's easy to pick out a mattress here i
picked out the medium there's different
i'll tell you all about it
ryan you'll be excited to this you got
to get yourself a helix mattress you
know it's great because helix has this
quiz
that you could take it's just two
minutes don't worry i failed every quiz
this is a quiz you don't fail you
succeed by doing this quiz
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique and helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers that's right i i took the
quiz
and i'm a medium ryan i'm a medium and
you know what's great is it's it's a big
upgrade to the last mattress i have
it's just it's a really supportive a
mattress that's that's comfortable
that's comfortable for me and i go
through a lot of mattresses trying to
find the right one
and bingo i did
it's been awesome getting messages from
so many of you who also found that helix
mattress
is uh working for you i've had actually
friends text me is this a really good
mattress
dude seriously i'm like yeah it's
actually a good mattress
i don't want to talk about things that
aren't good so look if you're looking
for a mattress just
take the quiz order the mattress that
you're matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store
again and you know how much that makes
me smile
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress of
2020 by gq
and wired magazine and all we have to do
folks to get a better
night sleep is go to helix sleep.com
inside take their two minute quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com slash inside
that's helix sleep.com inside for up to
off and two free pillows inside is
brought to you by nitsa
you know it's a fact that a child's body
temperature rises three to five times
faster
than an adult's and leaving a child in a
hot vehicle can lead to their death
very quickly sadly in 2020 24 children
died of pediatric
vehicular heat stroke and many of these
incidents
occurred when parents or caregivers
simply forgot
the child was in the car unintentionally
leaving a child in a car is a tragedy
that can happen to anyone
please please set yourself reminders on
your cell phone or place something
you'll need in the back seat to help you
remember that your child
is still in the car if your partner or
caregiver is taking your child to
daycare
check with them or the child care staff
to make sure that the child was dropped
off
and when you've arrived at your
destination always check to make sure
the car is empty
heat stroke deaths are preventable when
adults take the proper precautions
be safe and always look for your baby
before you lock
paid for by nitsa you know it's
very seldom it's rare that you know uh a
man a young guy like yourself
has published books and music and been
on hit tv shows and
um you know paints and is is learning
about himself and is more comfortable
with himself at such a young age
especially born you know growing up in
hollywood it seems to me
that if anything i i should be talking
to some guy who's uh
just getting off uh coke binge uh well
no it's interesting
no no no i understand what you're saying
i i get it and
to some extent i mean i feel like
i feel like i've i've lived i've lived
you know
at some point i've lived a version of
that life and um
it didn't work for me you know what i
mean it didn't serve me
and i have a lot of friends that have
have gone down a a darker path and
thus never returned and uh i've seen it
you know what i mean and i've had
i've had it very close to me so i feel
like
in some ways that the destruction and
the misery
created um around me kind of taught me a
lesson before
i myself fell too deep into something
and um and for that i'm really grateful
you know i was
i was kind of given a glimpse into many
many different lives and i
i'm just i'm just lucky i mean i you
never know but i'm
very lucky at this one singular point
so you saw whether it's friends or just
people in the industry
you had enough foresight or whatever to
acknowledge i'm not going down this path
i'm not allowing myself to go any
further down and i'm sort of like
hindering or lingering in this like area
this gray area
and i've just got to take off now i've
got so much potential
and i've got so much life to live is
that sort of a conscious thought or
something that took years for you to
sort of understand yeah i know it
no you're it's well what it is is like
growing growing up in hollywood i that's
why i brought up the book earlier it was
like a lo
it was a love letter to a town that now
i mean it feels
totally different but and i knew at the
time when i was photographing hollywood
that it was a period piece
i knew that i had a responsibility as a
as a photographer as an artist as
in some ways i had a creative amuse
within me that
allowed me to see the temporary nature
of
of hollywood and at the time you know
this was way before any that any
accountability
structures were put in place um and i
saw so many
so many failings in um
in not only hollywood but just in in
growing up
in california in general and
and how like how that how that shaped me
was
just being so close to it like being
able to
feel the heat radiating off of bad
decisions
and um being able to step back far
enough that i
saw the train wrecks but i wasn't
injured too badly from them
wow yeah i know it absolutely makes
sense i think that's what happens to all
of us i remember being 13 years old
13 i think i was 13 years old i was in
eighth grade
and i was really small from my age and i
remember i went over to
this guy kid's house and other kids i
won't mention their names right now
um one's in prison but uh i remember
they were huffing
gas they were just like
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you guys
doing
and they're huffing gas rosenbaum get in
here
huff some gas and i was like no
i can't i'm allergic to gas or whatever
the [ __ ] i said i don't know i got it
and then i just remember there was
it was just these at this age i look
back
how are they this [ __ ] up
and there's all these and by the way uh
two of those kids ended up you know
being
really big bullies and lo trouble with
the law one guy went to prison
i remember something inside of me
and it wasn't that i had the best
childhood because boy i did not
but uh you know people always have it
worse i mean you just kind of move on
but
i remember just
leaving cutting through yards
and going i don't belong here this is
wrong
something no one had to tell me
something inside of me said as a 13 year
old boy
this is not right and that was a gift i
don't know it was a
gift from god or whatever you call it
but as a 13 year old kid you're used to
succumb to all the you know the peer
pressure and the
you know people say come on rosenbaum
like oh yeah i guess i should do that
because they're doing it
and i don't know why but i just knew
that i needed to get the [ __ ]
out of there and maybe that's in a way
what happened to you when you're seeing
all these things you're like you know
what
this is there has to be that moment that
enlightening moment right
oh yeah man it's spirits i mean i like
to look at it as like it's a spirit's
guidance like you
you have like an inner counselor and you
can listen to it it's a gut i mean gut
instinct
you know gavin debecker wrote a really
great book about the gift of fear um
that's a crazy book um but that we all
have this gut
instinct that kind of um protects us
and you know even now it's it's
interesting
as i'm older i mean you always want to
you always want to see the best in
people and sometimes you'll see
something that's benevolent
in front of you and you go no they can't
i can't do that to them
they don't mean it and like no man
my gut usually is like it'll it'll be
like nah dude
they mean it it's it's real and so that
i've always really trusted my gut
instinct
and it sounds like it was good that you
did too um
because you have you have these um split
universes
where there's i mean the multiverse
theory is really
astounding but you have a split universe
where you make a choice and you're
there's a version of you that's living
in the other choice right now
of choices that you've made and there's
no way to tell if you're
good if it's a good or bad choice it's
just
you know you're always kind of
zigzagging through that reality
so i always like to try and make sure
that i'm making conscious decisions
that are that in the long term i'll i
won't
i won't regret but i also yeah i'll
understand why i made them
you know but there's always bet you know
no matter how good you are
yeah there's always the bad that's
always yeah you always [ __ ] make some
mistake for sure well not only that
i'm thinking you know you're doing the
right thing a lot of times and there's
some dark thoughts along those ways
where you could easily stray from the
good and go bad you're like ah you know
what [ __ ] you know [ __ ] it
and there it's not like it's all
positive thinking
during that positive thought of of
things that you're doing i don't know if
i'm making much sense here
and you're doing the right things and
you continue to do the right things
there's always that dark force that's
always
little things oh yeah man it's just a
concatenation of
thoughts that yeah i hear you man and
that's and that's something that you
know
you constantly as a human being it's
like not talked about enough and i think
that's
like that's kind of why there's a mental
health issue that's
that's rampant in in just
our our whole society and it's
it spans through urban environment and
rural environments because people are
you know it's just what is the the quote
and fight club like
our great war is a spiritual war like we
we have uh especially being being a man
right right now in in 2021
um you know it's something that i i want
to be the best version of a human being
and i want to keep getting better and i
want to learn from my mistakes i want to
i want to actually not just say it in a
false altruistic way on
instagram or right you're like i want to
be a better guy like i don't i actually
do like i want to
learn from the things that i did
incorrectly and
if if if i'm the only judge of that i
want to be able to
understand why i did certain things or
said certain things or
made certain decisions and then learn
from them down the road and
a lot of that you know it lends itself
to
being a being a better person from for
myself
not not really for anybody else isn't
that the truth that's the
you just nailed it like we could sit
here and try to
make you know ryan here my engineer and
i want ryan to think i'm a great guy
and you know and i want people to look
at me and go oh he really tries hard and
he really loves everybody
but i'm a [ __ ] up i am a [ __ ] up i i
need to
i need to believe all the things that
some people are believing
and i need to make those thoughts become
a reality i need to
work on myself but also knowing that not
being too hard on myself like
that that's important because we are
going to [ __ ] up you know look
it always you always hear you have to
love yourself first right it's like
you can't love anybody else so i you
know i don't ask that question much but
it's like
some it looks like you love yourself
because you've been working on yourself
a lot and i think that's important
yeah it's hard to say that i took a lot
of
of of figuring out like what what i was
missing
so i felt like i was missing things
within myself
and i went on this like whole journey
and i have a really
great group of friends around me that i
very
bespoke to self-betterment and
jared is definitely one of those people
as well like jared is
is an incredibly open oh yeah um
source of you know you would think so
you would think someone like jared would
be
you know he wouldn't get this part
he gets it and he's so open and he talks
and he's and he's like a loving
man which is yeah very palpable
and wonderful especially on set working
with him and being brothers
it was an immediate click and i have
great friends around me that you're like
hey you should read michael a singer's
the untethered soul hey you should wear
read gary zukovs the seat of the soul
hey you should get into saad guru hey
you should start doing yoga hey you
should start
like i have friends that are all about
that and i used to when i was younger i
have friends that were like here have a
drink
ah man you know [ __ ] all that do this
like do this escape this way and it
never helped you know it didn't help it
made it
actually it it amplified the the
resistance within me and so
you know just recently um especially
being here in austin i've been able to
really
focus on not just self-love but just
like
understanding myself better and finding
peace because dude it's so easy to lose
control especially in today's world
where you're just alone with yourself
and you're being spoon-fed constant
chaos you know constant i you know
what's funny is after this interview
i'm going to ask suzanne your publicist
who i've known for you she was my
publicist on
smallville and uh she's awesome for for
working this out but i'm gonna be like
get his email because i need to know
what i need to read i wanna get through
i wanna i wanna read the top [ __ ] don't
look you've read a lot of books you're a
reader uh
and dude do you know what you should
read right like honestly we should get
off here is read james nestor's um
breath it's it's called it's called
breath uh the
the new science of a lost art amazing
and that's the first book that's the
first book you want me to read
no no actually you know what read read
michael a singer's the untethered soul
untethered soul and it's an easy read
not two big words for me super easy read
you could even get it on uh audiobook
and just like
zone out to it it's pretty meditative
and then if you really like that you can
read the surrender experiment that's
another book that he did writing this
down ryan the surrender experiment
ryan's gonna read this [ __ ] help here we
need help
hey here's the other thing man like the
other part of it too
is is you know i wasn't ready for
for any of this until i was and
it did there were people telling me to
read and do and
work on myself for years and years and
years and i didn't
i didn't want to i tried and i didn't
really want it
and like the moment that and i'm i'm not
trying to speak from a place of ego it's
just like it
helps me now i don't know if it will
continue to help me i'm gonna keep
trying to put in work
but like dude it's so amazing when and
when it clicks
and you realize that you're
you're so much you're so much more than
what you think you
are without being anything at all it's
just a really great feeling wow you know
what i mean yeah
you know i think i the reason that we
don't
work on ourselves right away when people
read this and do this you're like no
no no because deep down in a weird way
at least for me is like i
i maybe i still believe this but i don't
believe that i'm fixable in a way
or i don't believe that it will work for
me my mind is different
it's this naivete that is just
it's just not real it's like come on you
even if you have a pre-existing
condition let's say you have
some mental illness they say that even
if you have certain things you can
control
40 percent 40 or 50 i mean it just
depends on
what the issue is but i just feel like
you have to put the work in
it's just not going to have it's like
somebody expecting to be a movie star
i'm just gonna hang out by starbucks and
spielberg's gonna drive by he's gonna
see me
it just doesn't [ __ ] happen it
certainly doesn't happen to me it
doesn't happen to many people
so if you don't actually put the work in
what's gonna happen it's just you
nothing's going to happen is the answer
nothing's going to happen and when
you're saying that you know what you
said you said something really
interesting because i thought the same
thing
um and i've gone through a huge amount
of
of of introspection and and what you
said is like i don't think i'm fixable
or like although anything like that man
that that you should do some active
self-forgiveness and like forgive
yourself for buying into the misbelief
that you're not fixable
and like go deeper into why you feel
that way and then clear it
and move on because you might be holding
on to that
and it's probably holding you back from
a true version of yourself that you
could easily arrive at if you
if you stepped off of that plane of
thinking that you were unfixable
if you just arrived at that also dude
another thing that really helped me
and it's changed my life jared doesn't
want to hear a [ __ ] about it but it's
really helpful is don't eat refined
sugars and processed foods
just do not consume them and think of it
think of your body as a how
as a house like you wouldn't let just
anybody into your house
so don't let just ingredients that you
don't know of
in your body like give me an example
give me an example of some of these
products
don't eat refined sugar uh like cane
sugar
read you know understand that there's
more about the stevia
stevia's okay there's a lot there's a
the jury's out on
artificial sweeteners but um
you know there's one what is it called
uh
there's one that's like pretty good but
it's a laxative
and so you'll you'll you need a diaper
if you eat too much of it but um
what's that one i would just don't eat
try and remove
refined sugar from your diet okay in at
at all costs
you can have honey you can have propolis
um like beet pollen or like uh royal
jelly if you
need eating fruit you off fruit is good
but don't eat it and
like don't eat it after like a certain
time like find out what
you know because it's a hot you know
some some fruits are pretty high
glycemic foods so if you eat like a
banana at night you're gonna
spike your blood sugar oh great but yeah
man that'll help a lot with mood and
anxiety
i noticed i gave up sugar in 2017
um completely and i was a pre-diabetic
i ate i would be at are you in la
i'm in la yeah i would go to the beverly
hills
atm sprinkles atm two in the morning and
get
four cupcakes and eat them on the
curbside uh sitting on my motorcycle
like a crazy jesus
inside of you is brought to you by
better help
better help online therapy i love it
because ryan
here he tried it out i did and he's
digging it i
i just started you just started you're
talking to people you're getting going
you're taking the initiative yep
i'm proud of you dude yep throughout the
month of june inside of you podcast is
proud to join the cause of
destigmatizing therapy so we're
actually proud of you ryan and you're uh
you know just it's good that you're
saying what the heck you know nothing
else works why can't i try
actually getting help here with real
trained people
uh if you're struggling with
relationships or having difficulty
sleeping or difficulty meeting your
goals if you're feeling anxious if
you're feeling stressed
better help counselors can listen and
help better help will assess your needs
and match you with your licensed
professional uh you can start
communicating in under 48 hours did you
start talking within 48 hours yeah even
quicker
really so they're on it it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's a
professional counseling done
securely online therapists have a broad
range of expertise
that may not be available locally in
your area the service is available for
clients worldwide
just log into your account anytime and
send a message to your counselor
and what's great is you can schedule a
weekly video
phone or even live chat sessions what
are you doing ryan uh yeah weekly video
weekly video so you see the person i
like to see the person yeah i think that
helps i think it does too yeah but
to each his own better help is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches so they make it easy and free to
change counselors if needed
honestly you might meet someone that
you're like i just don't vibe with them
i just don't feel comfortable so we get
you another one that's what betterhelp
does
they make it easy it's more affordable
than traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available ryan we
talked about that right before the
podcast it's you know i remember doing
it it was like 300
uh and uh it's a lot cheaper you told me
the prices and i was pretty shocked to
see how much lower
they are than normal it's a lot better
yeah so many people have been using
better help that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
uh and our listeners get 10 off their
first month on
online therapy at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside do yourself a favor try
better help inside of you is brought to
you by untuck it you can see i'm wearing
an untucked
shirt i love these shirts they feel
amazing and they're designed to be worn
untucked this is perfect for someone
like me who likes to be
laid back relaxed and you know every
once in a while yeah i'll go to a
barbecue i'll i'll look sharp
i'll just put on an untucked shirt and i
feel relaxed and
and the shirt's not down to my knees
ryan there's nothing worse than that
father's day is june 20th so if you
haven't found the perfect gift yet look
no further
untuck it is right there for you they're
designed as i said to be worn
untucked so they have comfort built in
uh they're perfect for the summer plus
untuck it has fits for all shapes and
sizes including slim
tall and relaxed so they can help dads
of all shapes and sizes look sharp even
at his most casual
look at me 190 pounds of
just pure relaxation right here the
untucked shirt is perfect for summer and
barbecue
who wouldn't want to unwrap some of our
top new styles like performance shirts
with stretch that wick sweat and short
sleeve styles to keep you cool
and of course our most comfortable polos
they're the official shirts
of summer you know ryan most of
untucker's gifts ideas
are under a hundred dollars whoa yeah so
you could buy a gift for dad
and get one for yourself too so remember
if you need the perfect gift for
father's day
look no further untuck it sure it's
designed to be worn
untucked use code inside for 20
off your first purchase at untuckit.com
that's
u-n-t-u-c-k-i-t dot com
untuck it um you know
let me get into really quickly
i want to get into uh pretty little
liars because that was your first big
hit that was like that was the thing
that kind of puts you on the
on the radar right you know how old were
you when pretty little liar started
i was very young i i i must have been
it was 2009 i got the call i remember
getting it and i was
so young i just skateboarded i
skateboarded to the audition so you were
20.
it's 20 yeah so you skateboarded to the
audition
did you have a fear at all did you go in
there and not give a [ __ ] you know it
was the first
so it's interesting it was like the
first i had gone on so many auditions
for so many different things and i was
doing background work on another
like kind of teen show and i remember
talking to one of the
actors on it and being like dude do you
have any pointers
on like how to be an actor like a
working actor like making money like
this doesn't seem
realistic like because i was doing
background work you make like 60 bucks a
day or something
just enough to like buy yourself a
couple meals before you know
and um he was just like he he looked at
me and he's like honestly
just don't give a [ __ ] and i'm like
really that's all it takes that's the
key
but what was interesting is i i cared so
much about i was going into acting
classes and
i still care so much it's interesting
because i
as much as i you you're supposed to not
you're supposed to like
release yourself from the the end result
of
your work you're supposed to be present
in it i went in for that audition and i
was just i just had so much fun i
remember having so
much fun in that audition and um
you know they tell you don't wear
beanies don't cover your eyes i went in
with sunglasses and a beanie on
i did all the things you're not supposed
to do
there you go that's the key did you 11
years ago was there instagram
we actually our show is one of those it
was probably
the show that kicked off the social
media
frenzy around live tweeting around uh
just social media in general where fans
were essentially steering
the shows uh arcs character
progression i was only supposed to be in
six episodes
my character dies in the book series um
but fans at that time social media had
gotten you know
starting to get a fire under it and fans
were demanding that they didn't kill
tobias kavanaugh which is my character
they're just like do not kill him well
what do you tell the author what do you
tell the guy who writes the book
no he dies sarah shepard wrote a book
series
and it was it's not to come back in full
circle here but
her universe ran parallel until it
didn't with marlene king's version who
she developed and was the showrunner of
our
of pll along with oliver goldstick and
they married the two in certain ways and
then
divorced them in other ways and one of
the divorce factors was
my character living and having a
very um strong relationship with one of
the main
characters that was just beautiful were
your parents blown away i mean are your
parents the kind of parents
that say keegan we're so proud of you
you're so good yes you're so sweet we
love you they're that
just adorable and painfully supportive
and i love them both my father passed
away in 2012 he got to see a glimpse of
the
of the i remember like you know he was
an
actor himself he he came from you know
broadway and very thespian and and
you know he he's he was in a star he was
in star trek and he would get fan mail
all the time
um he played like a small role in star
trek three
and he would get these crazy amazing fan
letters and he loved it it was like the
happiest
that he was when he was answering fan
mail for star trek
so when we were out one time uh
because my my dad was you know my dad
was going through some stuff but we were
out
spending time together and someone came
up to me
from iraq and they're like we watch your
show there and he was just like what the
hell
across the world like that that's
amazing
and i was like dude that made me so
happy and it was like a couple of months
before he passed away
and he was able to like see the the
reality of
how far reaching this this audience was
that is beautiful and it actually puts a
tear in my eye because i think about
it's just it's just so nice when a
father could be
just love his son so much and want to
see him
be successful and be so
you know just in awe of something like
that where
you know i it just for me especially it
just it just is
it's a beautiful thing is he i don't
know it was just
the relationship i could just see it
like when you were just talking about it
i just envisioned it i could see it and
just this
this guy who just cares about you and
was like wow follow from the other side
of the world how does he
how do they recognize you from just and
what that does is that creates this
sort of feeling inside you i'm sure
where it's just like
it just feels good that your dad feels
good about what you're doing and what
you've like
it just that's that's such a fulfilling
feeling
isn't it it is very special and i had a
very close relationship with my parents
um
and my dad you know it's weird it's like
when he passed away
i mean it was so weird because you know
i i
the one thing that we would do together
is we'd fish together we'd fly fish
together which is like
in itself another art and craft that i
still i've been doing it for
31 years and i still suck at it dude
i like to imagine myself that i'm a
master angler at this point
and then i go out on the on the river
and i'm like i can't
i'm what am i doing like why can't i do
this my dad was a master angler he was
he was so good he fished for
you know what 70 years or something and
so we would go and spend time like that
together but after he died like i still
go fishing and i still almost feel like
he's there
it's the weirdest it's so strange
um it's comforting i believe that i
believe he is though
yeah yeah i it's a strange thing it's
the one thing that i still can't quite
understand i don't know if it's just my
own imagination
and but i don't know well i you know my
best friend was my grandfather who died
a year and a half ago
and he by far he was my best friend
and uh i mean i i couldn't stop
videotaping him from the time i was a
kid
i just thought he was the funniest
awesomest guy in the world
and he always golfed and i never liked
golf
he would take me and i just never and
during this pandemic for the first time
i said [ __ ] well golf's really the only
thing i could do
so i would uh i'd go golf and you know
you're with one guy and you're separated
and you're social it's a sport that you
could play you got your own ball you're
touching your own balls that didn't
sound right
but you know for me i always feel like
herbs with me and i feel like there's
some kind of awesome
fee it's just this feeling where i'm
like my grandfather always wanted me to
go
[ __ ] why didn't i golf as much with him
and now
i just feel like there's this there's
this essence like erv here i go
could you help me out apparently not
because i'm sucking up
but there is a nice feeling i don't know
whatever it is it's just uh
like you said spirit you said you're
more spiritual and you know
it's who's to say what's out there right
i mean it's yeah especially during
quarantine i i really
i leaned into my fears i was very afraid
of the dark i had a really irrational
fear of the dark
um actually i was doing a podcast right
before quarantine
and that's why i have this mic and the
whole you know setup
is you know it's wonderful to have for
zooms yeah but
um my podcast immediately became
dated and strange because uh i took
i took a hiatus from my season one from
my podcast
it was really great ratings had millions
of listeners it was awesome
but then i realized that i i was talking
about aliens
i was talking about weird stuff and i
wanted to really
gauge my audience into what i've learned
that has made my life better
and one of the things was i was afraid
of the dark and i was afraid of the
forest and i had a house
in the forest that i was renovating for
most of 2018
and over a quarantine i moved into it
and overcame
my fear of the dark in the forest and
now i'm
like i just i feel like a completely
different person and a lot of that had
to do with
breathing oddly enough and sleeping by
that's why i said james nestors is a
great james nestor wrote a really great
book about breath
um because i was having these
hypnopompic and hypnagogic
hallucinations when i was
would wake up because i was breathing
through my mouth
because i wasn't practicing breathing
through my nose when i went to bed it's
so weird anyway but
uh i've gone through all these things
and i wish my father was around to see
it
i know he is technically by like the
spiritual realm and calming and all that
stuff
but like there is some there is
something to be said about like
you know or herb it's like it would be
so nice to just have
one day now and be like dude look look
at
this look at this yeah i think you'll
have that one day
yeah i mean that's the i mean people
could laugh at that and they could scoff
but like why is it so incredulous to
think that
maybe you will see somebody after these
people who are such cynics who just talk
you know it's it they're they're just as
bad as the extreme religious people in
my opinions
the people who just throw religion at
you and you're gonna die if you don't
they're just as worse as these yeah you
could be atheist
i don't know if i believe the word
atheist but you can be whatever you want
i don't care what you are
but i i don't like when um they sort of
scoff or make fun of people for
believing that
you know my father i think is you know
the the spirit of him is still
is still with me you know they can make
fun i just i just never understood that
and you know
whatever helps you get through life and
you know the biggest joke would be when
you finally pass or go to the next realm
it'd be like
ah see look there's dad right there you
[ __ ]
you know you nobody knows you don't know
what's what's what's after
you know life after death you don't know
what nobody knows anything i mean now
all of a sudden it's like the government
has these things with the
the aliens and the ufos and there's a
they come on
it's just a matter of time we're gonna
probably see aliens within the next two
years
they they probably know they've they've
known these [ __ ] aliens have been
here for years trust me i know does
anybody go on clubhouse anymore
for sure there's some crazy stuff so is
your podcast available again now
i'm working on it you know i'm i'm
what's it called revamping it it's
called foreverland podcast forever lance
so you guys
listen look for that once he's ready to
bring that back this is called [ __ ]
talking with keegan and this is rapid
fire so just really quick
emily s these are my patrons out there
they get to ask some questions emily
asks have you been doing uh
what have you been doing to stay sane
during the pandemic yoga
meditation i almost slammed myself in
the face painting
painting nico what's the best way uh you
found to deal with stress
meditation
and honestly too i would say meditation
and
playing a very calming video games uh
leanne p
who are some of your personal heroes oh
man my mom
my dad my uncle my aunt my best friend
brett
my best friend ryan my best friend brock
wow um jared jared's amazing jen
genevieve padalecki they're just all
really
great my manager conrad look at that
he has good people around you side guru
he's great
so mark hyman sorry it's like your oscar
awards
one more if i'm forgetting anybody uh
sophie m i'm gonna
just simplify this question did you
audition for walker or did you get asked
to audition or just get an offer
yeah you know i i auditioned and uh
i am so happy that i got to meet anna
fricke in the room she's the showrunner
of walker
and get to meet lindsay and and be able
to do
like probably one of the last network
tests before this pandemic
i mean i'm a theatrical guy so i just
man i loved the process not a lot not a
lot of actors loved that process
i loved that process with such a passion
dude i had so much fun
it was crazy that's great because it's
also important like you know you guys
out there you think
you know sometimes actors get offers
i've had offers
where it's it's it's better when you can
audition
and you know what they like and you got
the audit you got the part because you
know what they
want and you go to set and you know when
you get an offer you go to set and
you're like i hope they like what i'm
preparing here
and if not you've got to make a complete
180 or whatever
so it's kind of frightening and i i lost
a job because it was just like oh i was
doing something that they just weren't
you know
because i didn't audition it was a
straight offer and uh
you know that was tough so uh olga
c name one movie you'll never watch
again
oh god that's too hard isn't it
i can name 50 just off shutters you know
honestly can i tell you something really
spooky i i got you know i
along with you know doing all the
self-help stuff i get into deep youtube
video pits and just the worst
like i used to think that there were
movies that would never shock me
there's like a whole list of movies that
um
are online that even just researching
them just turn your stomach
so i just i would say i would say
honestly
a movie that i would never watch again
is cats the musical
i didn't see it don't you know
this has been fantastic i i didn't know
you and and
and yet and now i want to know you more
like this is just i should we should do
another we should do another podcast and
get into more stuff
i'm not kidding because this is just the
beginning it feels like
okay i need to do some reading i need to
do some work on myself
and then i need to talk to keegan again
you know what i mean oh man i i enjoyed
it man i honestly appreciate you and i
have such a reverence for your journey
that you've been through and
um god man i mean your smallville is a
total
interesting i mean talk about picking
apart not only just warner brothers
making
that show in general and like how crazy
ahead of its time it was but also just
the
how each actor has what it meant to each
actor and what it did to each actor it's
such an
interesting uh show it took my life into
a completely different direction i was
mostly playing you know i was doing some
comedic performances
and um i think i just at the same time
did sorority boys and like you know some
uh you know i think i did sweet november
was right before that so i was i was
doing some drama too i did midnight in
the garden of good and evil
but when i really got smallville that
jumped me into like oh serious actor guy
and my friends would make fun of me
they're like you
you're lex luthor dude you're such a
goof how are you
i'm like because you can't be if i was
oh a serious guy
that that character probably would have
been the death of me i have to once that
they say cut
i'm laughing farting doing whatever to
get out of that character and
it took time for like people like john
glover tony award winner who
was my father who's just amazing to
understand and one day he goes
i know what you're doing now i go what
am i doing guys
you're being michael so you can then be
lex
and you're being michael to annoy me
off camera because lex annoys lionel and
he has this whole theory about this
thing and i'm like i don't know
i think you're thinking too hard i just
don't like to be lex when i'm not lex
but look when when can we when do we
watch walker it's on cw what nights
on cw and it streams on cw the next day
but i believe it's a thursdays at 8 7
central
um on the cw but after season one finale
it goes to hbo max which is really cool
i could be saying
all this wrong but i mean just um
yeah i'm really excited about it man
it's a really cool show and
um it's a real departure from what
people
thought it was going to be and i think
the more that
it's the more that people dive deeper
into the
to the to the root of this story the
more it hits home with
with a really grounded and painful
uh story about loss and dealing with
loss which
you know is just ever present in jared's
character
ever present in the walker family ever
present in
all of the arms that reach out from all
of the different character storylines
and plot points
and it it's it's truly a remarkable show
to work on
and uh and a dream job for sure and
weren't the ratings like for the
premiere episode like just off just
unbelievable i i heard that they did
that we did really well
and i'm so happy to hear it because um
obviously like i want to keep working on
this i want to keep this k
i want to get to know liam better but i
also
am so excited that people are enjoying
the story and seeing it from from so
many different perspectives and
and and holding on to i mean everything
about it is just so fun to work on man
i'm like such a fan of the show i watch
it
which is so not like me i mean i'm just
now starting to
re watch some like there's been a
resurgence of pretty little liars
stuff um you know where you could stream
it and i've been kind of re-watching it
and being like oh my god i don't
remember
any of this i don't remember anything
about this
so it's been fun to you know kind of
sort of dip my toe into that but
i watch walker and i'm i'm a fan of the
show as well as i
awesome as an actor on it yeah well hey
guys check out walker it's thursday
nights
on the cw and uh i mean look this guy's
keegan this has been a real treat again
you know you sometimes
you don't know your guests you don't
know where things are going and you're
like oh okay
but then i just immediately was like
wait a minute this guy is really
interesting he's got a story and
i love the relationship with your
parents and and the love they gave you
and that you did go through a lot of
[ __ ] that you were raised in hollywood
you turned out to be a great guy
and uh you you've done the work and
you're still doing the work and um i can
i really appreciate you sharing your
story with us
thanks man you're a mensch i appreciate
you too you too um
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
you and uh we'll talk again
she's
[Laughter]
uh another good conversation with uh
someone i i didn't know
and i always liked that meeting someone
for the first time and then getting to
know them in the in the brief time that
we have together so
thank you keegan allen i hope you guys
enjoyed the podcast please subscribe
um you can subscribe on youtube and um
apple stitcher spotify all that write a
review
um and our handles are at inside of you
pod on the twitter at inside you podcast
on instagram and facebook and uh i
really appreciate your support
go to the inside you store if you want
the the new uh
merch code summerrosy10
uh a bunch of great stuff and then also
if you can go to sunspin.com if you want
any um sunspin stuff it's a
sun spin summer 10 for 10
off so i'll start out with this this
lovely letter
from paul hey my name is paul i'm a huge
fan of yours and of course
smallville now your podcast i'm 42 years
old
a former marine and that's where i want
to thank you i served in the marines for
three and a half years been in iraq
afghanistan where i blew out my knee and
had to leave service i had ptsd and had
to learn how to cope with it but i
started listening to your podcast in the
beginning of the year
listening to all the movie stars etc
having mental health issues stress and
anxiety and how you go through this as
well helped me out
um it relaxes me to listen to how your
guests deal with
it i like how you tell your how your
life goes and all those stories
i could tell you that you do help people
with your podcast and that you are a
very funny and good person
please keep doing it thank you really
you might have saved a life or two
a fan named paul
well paul that means the world to me and
that's why i wanted to read your letter
um
you know i do what i can i didn't i
didn't think i was doing anything with
this podcast other than just talking to
people
and it was until i started getting
letters and comments or people came up
to me at conventions that i started
realizing
wait a minute the podcast is helping
these people but why is this
why am i how am i helping anybody and i
think just
you know trying to be honest and trying
to you know get things out of my guests
that
help all of us maybe it's selfish maybe
i just try to
get something from the guests for myself
and in return it actually
goes to everybody out there um but i'm
glad it helps you
and uh i'll i'll keep doing it as long
as i can
and uh thank you paul thank you for the
letter uh if you want to join patreon
join the wonderful family the community
that keeps uh getting
bigger and more loving and uh you won't
really you don't really know what it's
about until you join so i
recommend it i'll shoot you a message
when you join just go to patreon.com
you p-a-t-r-e-o-n i love all my patrons
and right now i'm going to read their
names so here we go all right
nancy d mary b leah s trisha f sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h lauren
g nico p
robin asked jerry w robert b jason w
apithean
kristen k not to be confused with
kristin krook amelia oh allison l
lucas m raj c joshua d emily s cjp
samantha m jennifer n jackie p stacy l
carly h carly s jen asks jamal f janelle
b
taba the 272 not to be confused with
kristen crook ashley
you bastard i think tabitha 272 just
sticks around because she likes to hear
that oh all right with the 273 i think
so
all right we'll just ask defeat we'll
feed that we'll just feed it every month
ashley ryan kimberly mike eldon supremo
99 more ramirez san diego m sarah f chad
w liam p
ray a maya p maddie s kendrick f ashley
shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v james r
chris h dave h samantha s spiderman
chase sheila g
ray h tabitha t tom and suzanne b
liliana a
michelle k marcus b w marcus
w hannah b michael b talia m
michael s andrew t betsy d claire m
liz j laurel chad l rochelle nathan e
taylor k marion s meg k janel p
trav l dan and diane r ah jeddah
lorraine g corey m veronica k big stevie
w kendall t
carol d sandy b angel am er
eric c rhiannon c stephen m chord case
super sam emily c
sherry s coleman g david c michelle a
matt w
liz l jeremy c andy t cody r and chris
e those are the lovely patreons you
could join patreon patreon.com
inside of you um i hope you enjoyed this
podcast and please continue listening
i'm gonna put on my
smaller glasses now so i don't look
completely crazy
but uh i wonder if like ever after we're
done recording a podcast maybe not today
but like
right when we're done recording it while
things are converting we just go up the
street a little ten minute there and
back
take a walk interesting maybe we'll do
it you do live in the
hollywood hills of california yes
michael rosen i'm here from the
hollywood hills in california
and ryan tears from the hollywood hills
california give a little wave
to the camera uh thank you for for
joining me again i love doing this and
uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you i
hope you have a glorious week
be healthy do something good for
yourself try to love yourself a little
bit
i'm trying trying to do that and uh
all right i think that's it